a hundred thieves on the verge of
destroying ascend ripping the lead away
from them as zeke and c ned need to rise
above and they can't do it nitro to
close
applause
if you can find a player like that and
and simply eliminate him from the game
by not even entertaining him um then
it's massive i mean it's no secret that
cned is a huge win condition for ascend
dives back here that's one that's two he
needs more he gets four three oh wait my
word he's giving them a chance here with
ascend they've been to you know the
biggest stages in the last couple of
events maybe the results haven't been
what they wanted but clearly they're
good enough to get here through a very
difficult region in the eu so they
should really feel confident coming in
today
he's already seen one pass cena finds
one it's all on red car now
and this is what it comes down to one
more man to stand and red gone
all the hours you've put in
thousands upon thousands is down to a
1v4 and it's done ascend are your
ballarat champions winners
after ascend won valerian's first online
european major everyone expected their
star player cned to dominate
internationally i'm sinnet i'm 19 years
old i'm from turkey and i'm playing for
essence the team took out heretics to
become the best in europe and after
cnn's performance everyone agreed that
he was among the best jet operas in the
game and one of the only players out
there capable of single-handedly winning
matches he's gonna be greeted by four
members of fbx if he does opt to go for
this though can he want to get away he
does again the mystic falls they're
going to try and charge him down here
zip and he's just on the other side oh
my god
shadow falls cena is insane right now i
think cena was probably the only
reasonable
you know example of of
somebody we saw do something that you
know wardell and tens were doing in the
early days of of north america but i
think he did it better um the the the
small additions that he was able to make
um even just the the use of his
positioning his uses of the smokes you
know his ability to create new angles
and almost play anti-flash off himself
we saw so many examples where i
he just demonstrated he was heading the
shoulders above with cena leading ascent
to european dominance everyone assumed
they'd be representing emea at
valerian's first international land but
then at challengers 2
everything fell apart the flank that
cnet is on could pay huge dividends as
well brahms peaks close good kill trades
back cned in the back has to go quickly
a 1v2 a player close he gets the first
mo going in for the 3k that shocked our
tags him and loki finishes it off 14
rounds for vitality they have knocked
ascend out the masters champions no more
defenders the two finalists of masters
one
heretics and ascend will not be going to
iceland they will not be representing
the european region they won't even make
it to the top eight across cis and
turkey that is a huge change and it
really goes to show that surprises can
happen in any given moment nobody on the
talent team predicted vitality was going
to get this one never mind in 2-0
fashion but there we are ascend
out of stage two cena's international
debut was denied in an upset loss to
vitality and ascend watched from the
sidelines as fnatic and team liquid were
paled as emea's best in iceland so after
missing out on valoran's first
international tournament ascend weren't
about to let another chance pass them by
he's gonna get caught out hundred
percent there's no way expected red
guard to be there why was he it was so
late into the push pink coming back
through another for regard it leaves it
all on to scene and there's no way he
gets that
[Music]
the bullets aren't connecting cned is
going to go through the smoke and take
that's down he's back out for more three
kills on the board for cnn they had the
option before and avoided it now the
dashing decide cena knows as a player
below has to dash out of the way knives
out and somehow zeke is just destroying
them
delivers the knives to defoe's head and
shanos is the last man standing he has
to hold on in a 1v4 and it is not
happening
13-5 that will be the masters one
champions as the first team to lock in
their place as an emea representative in
berlin despite the massive skill
disparity within the team hopes were
pretty high for ascend going into berlin
they made it out of their group and were
set up to face hundred thieves in the
quarter finals where at first it was
looking easy for ascend and they have to
be aware of the possibility come true
is finding the form that terrifies most
but hundred thieves fought back to take
it to a third and final map kayla's
still trying to do what he can and store
so he was at the bottom of the board
he's still fighting damage still finding
work and so is hiko a 1v1 out of nowhere
six bullets and a dream and on the other
side killers the [ __ ] shows and he go
he's clutching out again for a hundred
thieves this man does not know when he
is done breeze started out looking like
another free win for ascend as cena ran
the show but he knows there's gonna be a
close coming in here and it's from the
back lines ethan denied keyless decided
nitro's gone
this is the map we waited to see but
then while being just one round away
from the semi-finals the unthinkable
happened he's closed the gap ethan's
coming with another this could be it a
hundred thieves on the verge of
destroying ascend ripping the lead away
from them as zeke and c ned need to rise
above and they can't
[Music]
hundred thieves managed to pull off the
greatest upset in valor in history
specifically by shutting down ascend's
best player the na squad was a team of
veteran cs go competitors they had the
resilience needed to complete such an
insane comeback probably after the round
we we talked about that's that's when a
hundred thieves almost knew they'd
pulled it off like that that was the one
where it's like okay we sort of broken
them now and when you when you break a
young team like that it's it's so
difficult to get your head back in the
game whereas with 100 i mean you could
there must be like 35 plus years
combined of like you know veteran land
experience there um on that roster which
is it's worth its weight in gold in in
that scenario alone for ascend they're
inexperienced and at times arrogance
cost them on the world stage
cned was by far the only member of
ascend showing up at tournaments so if
they were ever gonna win on the
international stage the rest of his team
would have to step up but before they
could even think about their next event
cena became mired in unexpected
controversy
a turkish money laundering scandal swept
through twitch with many top valerant
pros involved and unfortunately for
ascend cned was one of them essentially
someone was using twitch bits donations
to wander dirty money cnet was one of
the players who got the bits but said he
knew nothing about the scheme so he
didn't report the donation to twitch
which pete later admitted was a mistake
despite the scandal cena and his team
attended readable home ground 2 where
they proved that they could go
toe-to-toe with some of the best teams
in valorant chronicle what you've got
for us nothing and now it's all down to
one this has been the wildest of games
we've seen in a while defoe at least
gonna find kilos but the rest looks like
a mountain in front of him that he has
to try and climb and oh the shots go
astray and so does the entirety of the
game it's
13-0 but despite their impressive
performance the narrative surrounding
ascend was still the same most people
thought they relied too heavily on their
star player i mean everybody on their
roster has had individual performances
but in terms of consistency and in terms
of
you know single impact there's the i
don't think anybody comes close to
seeing it on ascent which is no you know
kind of shun to them whatsoever seen as
a fantastic player but
if you can find a player like that and
and simply eliminate him from the game
by not even entertaining him um
then it's massive i mean it's no secret
that cned is a huge win condition for
ascend going into valoran's first world
championship ascend were handed what
many thought would be an easy group for
them to get out of but brazil's key
stars had upgraded their roster since
their last showing in berlin and they
shocked everyone in their opening match
against ascend zeke
one more a two versus two scenario and
they have to clear this man from the
flank it's left along to zeke to try and
close this one out but it isn't going to
be happening it is vivo
to head through it to the upper bracket
and ascend have already faltered in this
tournament following the match fans took
to social media accusing key stars of
using an illegal cipher camera on breeze
and later that night riot released a
statement riot decided the teams had to
replay the map starting with a 7-0 round
score in favor of ascend to account for
the total number of exploited rounds
plus an additional round for economic
impact but despite the 7-0 lead ascend
nearly choked the rematch they're gonna
have to make the choice to just almost
try and go through it but that benefits
their opponents more than anything else
starzo i think you should finish this
one there's only eight seconds left for
them to try and get onto this site they
have to run through and it is done it
took a single long time but it is not
quite enough for vivoki a valiant effort
to fight that one back which should have
been a fairly easy game to win turned
out to be brutally close and ascend
might have lost without the free
advantage they got from riot and on top
of that a lot of the communities saw
them as villains because of the whole
situation even though it was beyond
their control ascend bounced back with a
2-0 win over envy to earn a spot in the
knockout stage as the number one seed
from group a they're looking great and
they're gonna be pretty sick going into
the playoffs yeah they're the fourth
emea team to complete the perf the
perfection dan all four ema teams got
the high seeds what is this other
regions including n a come on we gotta
come up big in the quarters despite a
rough start to their group ascend showed
up when it mattered most and even more
importantly it wasn't just cned carrying
anymore no updrafts just a single cloud
burst with c dead holding the angle
talking about how much he loves watching
cnet play it's not going to be at his
hand but zeke is there to shut him down
ascend will take their map pick away
from them pulls back grabs the vandal
stops himself from getting suppressed
and giving away his position potentially
but
he's playing very close forward and he
strikes him down said i thank you for
being a fan but i must end your career
right here right now cned will get the
last one on the dispenser and there you
have it ascend took down team secret 2-0
and they were in the driver's seat the
entire time waiting for them in the
semi-finals was team liquid the fan
favorites who beat ascend just one month
earlier but when the match got underway
ascend flipped the script oh it's so
difficult here they go and they get
flashed and absolutely destroyed the
prime gaming flawless from ascend time
is against him he's just forced to go
forward he's 10 bullets 10 bullets and
three players the math doesn't add up
and bone cold takes his head clean off
there
he's holding up high he's got zeke oh
this guy is just absolutely unbelievable
here for ascend they can play the time
here yamp is in such a bad position what
can he do he's forced to have to just
hold they're gonna swing him and they're
gonna find themselves now in the grand
finals liquid have been dominated by
ascent all of a sudden ascend looked
invincible and it wasn't because cnet
was on fire it was because the whole
team was working together for the first
time but their grand finals opponents
weren't going to make it easy to truly
shut down the haters and finally give
cena the land win he'd been chasing for
so long ascend would have to go through
the berlin champions gambit
it's reassured possession
what zeke two kills out of nowhere and
suddenly this round becomes a little bit
more viable but time is the biggest
problem oh my word zeke is this when
you're going to step up and deliver but
it's going to be chronicle the body
the timing i don't think he's going to
have the time surely
surely
no way oh my god zeke has just destroyed
them and that's where the old comes in
as well kj all comes down zeke still
stands starzo on the back of the site
the spray towards maine and the spike's
been lost
i was gonna try and recover
strong again
33 hp now
oh and the aim from cnet comes in it's a
celebration from ascend gambit
bringing nothing out right now nats is
on the other side of this but all he has
is that specter he's already seen one
pass cena finds one it's all on red car
now
and this is what it comes down to one
more man to stand and red guy
all the hours you've put in
thousands upon thousands is down to a
1v4 and it's done ascend are your
ballarat champions winners
by becoming the first ever vct champions
ascend proved that they're not just a
bunch of unaligners and that they didn't
have to rely on their star player
cena proved that resilience is what
makes a champion despite all the times
his individual skill wasn't enough he
kept on fighting it is our distinct
honor to crown our inaugural vct
champions give it up for ascend
and in the end it wasn't cena alone that
led ascend to victory the whole team
worked together allowing him to finally
take his place as the true king of
valorant
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification bell for unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit us up on our twitter instagram
facebook and tick tock